Remove the diffuser bands.
Stand back, Henrietta.
(electrical humming)
She's alive, alive!
- I'll go get the bouquet.
- Hey.
- The bride of Frankenstein...
- The bride of who, now?
- This is unbelievable, she speaks.
- I guess there wasn't a pants option.
She's for me? What a pleasant surprise.
- No! No, no, no.
For him.
- (groaining)
Mine?
(gagging)
- Oh don't worry buddy, she likes you.
- So, how long have you
been in the monster field?
- About four years,
I'm saving up to go to veterinary school.
- Mine?
- Yes, yes, yours.
- No, thank you.
- (laughing) The humor extract
took, very rare in a woman.
Anyhoo, let's get you two married.
- Oh no, I'm a lesbian.
- (groaning)
- You got a phillips-head
lying around here?
A lot of this stuff looking
pretty loose, pretty loose.
- (groaning)
- I'll go get the torch.
We should burn her.
- Babe?
- Where did I go wrong?
- Yeah, these things'll come right off
if you don't screw them in tight.
- Did I not add enough estrogen elixir?
- The old loosey-goosey.
- Did I add to many
pigments of independence?
- Nice finish, did you do this yourself?
- I failed.
- Okay.
- [Doctor] My creation
has turned against me.
- That's smooth. That's a good sand job.
- There is only one option,
the self destruct lever.
(grunting)
- Here, I'll get it.
I know this is probably weird for you
but I'm just not interested
in male monsters.
- I did everything right.
I followed every calculation correctly.
- Sorry you feel like
I'm letting you down,
but it's actually a
huge let down to realize
that the person who
made you is disappointed
in something so trivial.
It sucks, actually.
Alright well, your lever's fixed
so you can pull it if you want.
- I have the torch.
- No, there's no need for that Henrietta.
- Mrs. Henrietta.
- Look, I'm sorry. We've never met a...
- Lesbian monster?
- Hey, what do say we go out
and scare the hell out of some villagers?
- I'd like that.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Do you play ball?
- My team's looking for a pitcher.
- Well, somebody gave
me one hell of an arm.
- (laughs) Fantastic.
- [Monster] After you.
- [Doctor] Well, it looks
like I can make this place
into a sex-dungeon again.